the role is simple strategy falou I do
how did this happen Oh oh my I'm so
confused how this happened
you laugh you lose let's not laugh okay
it's not that hard it's not that hard
Peppino de novo Peppino Pepe Pepe no no
vu Pepito Pepito Pepito Pepito like a
delicate sometimes to conclude Pippin
Pippin Pippin he just went straight
dolphin I don't know where
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god Oh Oh bribe say bellissima
Wow that made me laugh I lost and lost
okay whatever this is like the oldest
mean I can remember someone that are
upper body I was so confused when I saw
this joke maybe on how are you gentlemen
all your days are long you are on the
way the dispersion what you say you have
known as their lies made your time
[Music]
it's a good it's a classic it's a
classic mean it was a mean before it was
me have you ever guys thought about that
you know there was a time before memes
were real
[Applause]
get gets me every time man have a Google
Translate I will proceed to type the
characters may translate to return and
I'll copy them and paste them twice it
changes to regret once more a
co-production once more
Eiffel Tower and one small delicious
breakfast and once more wait this is
real Jose thank you ok return regret he
could production Wednesday egg pling
iike production again delicious
breakfast this searing egg delicious
breakfast early evening dis searing egg
again delicious breakfast early morning
dis searing ego preparation delicious
antiperspirant Oh jag yeah
disturbing yeah get get get get
delicious breakthroughs of deep-sea
squeeze egg preparation egg delicious
soup with delicious soup with delicious
soup aigoo aigoo aigoo aigoo aigoo aigoo
aigoo aigoo aigoo aigoo aigoo aigoo
japanese language is such a beautiful
complicated language you're asking me
well
an amazing watch it's a dude it's a dude
it's dude
okay I'm in spot a dude from miles away
because I respect women
too much and there's no way a women is
gonna lie Camaro Chan origin or
neurotically okay all right all right
I love boku no pico man okay that's the
wrong music they look how happy I never
seen a man happier in my life
he just found love be happy
play some happy music
ah it's a simple question how how are we
gonna make change he's the worst
Hillary was calm down mom I'm watching
but I don't know if I would have
believed you if you had told me two
years ago
before I made my Heath a speech that we
might have the first female president of
the United States
[Music]
[Applause]
you're British you're British
you can't even vote you can't even vote
thank you for watching another laugh of
the loose did you laugh or did you lose
leave a comment down below recommend
some clips down in the subreddit and do
remember to da ba da ba doo buh doo buh
doo subscribe audience family squad
christian channel cacao squad fam out
this has been pewdiepie and bro best
yeah
you